[Music]
welcome to view from the top
today's event is dedicated to roanoke
desai
a member of the mba class of 2010
and a former view from the top a leader
who passed away right before graduation
his classmates describe him as a
remarkable
and accomplished individual who was
passionate about exploring how prominent
leaders can truly impact the lives of
millions and each year we dedicate one
talk
in his memory and now please welcome
dean levin to the stage
to introduce our distinguished guest
today
thanks adrian it's so it's a great
pleasure to welcome stacey brown
philpott to the
gsb virtual gsb today um
i think everyone probably knows
something about stacy she's had
just a spectacular career wharton gsb
google taskrabbit corporate boards
and amazing leader i wanted to just very
briefly share two things about stacey
that maybe not everyone
would have had the perspective on the
first is that stacy
joined the gsb advisory council just a
few years ago and
as in probably many of the roles she's
been and she was one of the youngest
people to join that group
and she is an incredible contributor
when stacy
talks everybody wants to listen and i
think you'll see that when
in this interview with jess guy and the
second is
stacy's kids and mine went to the same
elementary school
and stacy and chris are like at
every event and chris is normally
running them
and you know that just i think you're
going to hear a lot about a professional
career but
it just shows stacey is someone who she
really has her priorities
in the right place and and her values in
the right place so it's
it's she's an amazing alum and a great
person to have here at view from the top
and
welcome stacey great to great to see you
and
jessica looking forward to the interview
cece thanks for being here it's great to
have you back
at the gsv virtually hi
it's nice to see you and it's glad to
i'm glad to be back
it's so good to see you i mean it sounds
like you've really mastered zoom i know
you have a full household with
dogs and a kid but you're you're getting
through it and you're surviving
well i they're all invited so if they
show up i have no shame
i would love a cameo
bring them on stage i know we talked the
other day there are a lot of topics we
wanted to cover
from building community to embracing
change and driving
impact so i'm going to dive right in so
we have plenty of time if that's
okay with you great let's do it awesome
so
i want to start by taking us back to
your childhood in detroit and the early
influences in your life i know
you know one of the first jobs you had
was delivering newspapers with your
brother
at the age of 10 sometimes in four
degree weather which is crazy
i'd love to hear how experiences like
that and your upbringing
in detroit influence you know how you
think about
leading a business especially when
you're talking about community
yeah i i see my brother often because he
moved out to the bay area and he's like
fun uncle now with my kids because he
doesn't have kids of his own but
i remember when he wanted to have a
paper route and
he said my mom said yes we could do it
um and then
you know i could help him so i was kind
of the cfo of the paper route he was
like the ceo of the paper route
and it was hard in the winter it was
cold
and we still had to get we had a
responsibility to get out there
and deliver those papers and so it
taught us like
responsibility even when things are
challenging and we also had
accountability because sometimes people
didn't want to pay
so you know they the neighbors wouldn't
like answer their door
or they'd see us coming and look out the
window and close they knew they owed us
like ten dollars
if anyone's ever had a paper out you
have to pay for the papers before you
get your profits
and so we would figure out little sneaky
ways to catch people like getting out of
their car
so we could get our money right so we
had to hustle like
a lot of like that paper route taught us
hustles like responsibility and hustle
but it was a community it was really you
know we lived in a neighborhood that
wasn't the best neighborhood
but it was definitely a good
neighborhood and people looked out for
each other and they knew that
my brother and i were like working hard
and doing our best
and so most people did their part and
they paid us
there was always those one or two people
who like didn't want to
um so i i loved growing up in detroit it
was my home people often ask like
how could you imagine sort of growing up
anywhere else that's where i'm from
that's who i am that's where i'm from
and the community that i grew up in
taught me a lot about independence and
grit some of the things we try to teach
our kids today
in a real and very practical way
sounds incredible i don't know what i
was doing at 10 but it certainly wasn't
settling up with my
neighbors to collect debt so you sound
like a fierce
and fearless 10 year old that's
incredible
um and yeah you spoke about grit and um
you know sometimes grit is taught but
sometimes it's you know
required by terms of the environment
that you grow up in and i think
that grit that you inherited stuck with
you and got you to
the gsb eventually where you came
straight off of goldman's m
a tech team and you're doing deals that
really got you excited about silicon
valley
so you came to the gsb hoping to pivot
get your foot in the door at the tech
industry
and i think a lot of us today are hoping
to do just that i know i personally am
trying to get into the tech industry
but it feels like the pressure is really
on to get it right so
i'd love to hear from you what advice
you have for business school students
who are looking to pivot
but are really nervous that they're not
going to get it right the first time
around
yeah so you're probably not going to get
it right the first time around so if you
just
let yourself accept that truth then you
can move on
you can kind of release some of the
pressure when i came i didn't actually
know what silicon valley was
i was like i thought it was a place like
a city then you get here and you're like
what's the city of silicon valley like
no actually it's it's like this whole
area and so i was it was that foreign to
me
what i knew was that tech was exciting
it was 1999 and then those of us
who were on this call who were in my
class saw it all die
the day we showed up and we got yelled
at for not
going to clap for for like thinking
about not going to class and we're like
what else are we doing but i think the
classes before that
weren't coming to class so we got this
whole lecture about like coming to class
we're like no we're coming
because nowhere else to go nothing else
to do
so so we didn't i didn't get it right
because the economy wasn't great in 2002
in fact it was pretty bad
and i didn't know what i was going to do
next what i did know
was that the gsb was a great place for
me
to think differently about my life and
my career
and really i really embraced the
experience of
my classmates who really encouraged me
when i was about to graduate
and i didn't have a job and i was
thinking about what do i want to do like
i should just take this job and go back
to goldman
and there were so many of my classmates
who were like no you really want to be
in tech
you got to stick with it like i believe
in you you should believe in you and so
i would say lean on your classmates take
the risk that's why you're
at the gsb and it is the environment
where you can
make a change if you really put your
mind to it
and hold on to the reason why you went
to stanford
which was to make imagine a different
world and to make a different
impact in the world hold on to that
because that's what's going to get you
through that mistake
that you will inevitably make and you're
not going to get it right
and then when you do get it right you're
going to remember all those stories from
your classmates and your professors who
helped you
that is super reassuring i mean i'm a
second year mba
and i have no idea what i'm gonna be
doing in five months so i'm gonna hold
on to that
advice when it inevitably gets a little
bumpy so
thank you for that um but eventually you
did make your way to google not
immediately after but soon after you got
to google and you were a pretty early
employee i think there were about
a thousand employees when you got there
and you were there for just shy of 10
years and in that period you got
a lot done to say the least i mean you
established an incredible dni legacy by
starting the black googler network
you drove growth overseas through a
stint in india
you built out a massive online sales and
ops org i mean you're really really busy
and at the end of those contributions
you said you looked around
your corner office and you had the
assistant and the dog and the dog bed
but you started to feel like your next
mountain was elsewhere so
you decided to leave how did you come to
that
kind of hard decision and know to trust
your gut especially from where i'm
sitting it seemed like you don't have
you didn't have that many reasons to
to leave you had a lot of good things
going for you at google
it was so hard to leave google i
i always share that i first broke up
with google
before i decided that i was gonna go do
something else it's like this stable
at this point it had become like this
stable boyfriend who
who was just super comfortable and like
always gonna like cook me dinner at
night like it was
just it was great like there was nothing
wrong and
everybody was like wanted to work at the
company
but as i started to think about what my
own
purpose was and why i was here like why
am i on this earth
what am i doing here i felt like i had
fulfilled
my purpose in this great company
we had gone from 1 000 to 50 000 people
i did have that corner office i had
growing up in detroit i had like
everything any child who went to school
with me would have ever dreamed of
in terms of a job but i knew that
i there was more in there meaning
in me my gut was telling me there's more
and unfortunately stacy is not here with
this stable thing that you have
and my mom was very surprised when i
told her
i was going to leave google she was the
same person who said to me
when i went to google she said honey if
that google thing doesn't work out
you can always go back to goldman sachs
and so when i got the job at taskrabbit
she's like well if that taskrabbit thing
doesn't work out
you can always go back to google so i
feel like
she's got premonitions of like what good
things really are
in a very in a very special way but
something was calling me
to do something different and we feel it
and we know and sometimes
as humans we ignore what's in our gut
because we're getting advice and we're
thinking with our head
and a lot of times we got to put the
head aside and sort of lead with the
heart and i think
that's really what drove me to decide to
break up with this wonderful company and
and think about
what might be next that's incredible i
think that's a great
lesson a reminder to just because you're
comfortable doesn't mean
it's the right fit i know i probably
would have stopped at the dog in the dog
bed so i
i think it's good to kind of push
yourself to leaf through those moments
to get to your next
big thrill um and your next mountain was
taskrabbit in fact so you started as
ceo and ultimately made your way to ceo
of the company
and i want to spend a little time on
that because you know it's an incredible
feat to be a ceo of a tech company
it's doubly incredible to be a black
female ceo
of a tech company i mean those
descriptors don't come together
as often as they should and selfishly
for my own career because i would
love to aspire to something like that
i'd really like to know from you
what do you think are the two or three
qualities that
kind of put you on that upward
trajectory to the c-suite
i first of all i loved running
taskrabbit
it was like i found one mission which is
the mission of google and then i found
the mission of taskrabbit
around making everyday life easier for
everyday people and it really
was personal to me and so i think one of
the things that really helped me
to get there was to really pick
something
that i was passionate about that i cared
about that i
felt like connected to who i was as a
person
it made everything else so much easier
and it made a lot of things a lot
clearer too
the second thing was just surrounding
myself with
people who were better than me at
pretty much everything first thing i did
when i got there one of my old
managers from google emailed me my
second day he said
who have you hired i just got here like
what are you talking about he's like
who have you hired and so i went out and
i hired my vp of operations who went on
to become my ceo when i became the ceo
and he was just so much better than me
at running in operation so surrounding
myself with great people
was it and then the third one is just
willingness to learn
i i don't always know the answer in fact
i almost
always never know the right answer to
something but i
am willing to ask the question and i am
not afraid to be wrong
and to make a mistake and so i all those
things
helped me create an environment where i
could leverage my board i could ask the
right questions i could think
thoughtfully about partnerships
and really become the best leader that i
can for the company
i didn't start at taskrabbit with the
aim of being the ceo
i joined a ceo to become a partner
with an amazing founder who was building
an amazing business
and that was the partnership that we had
becoming ceo
was not the end goal fulfilling the
mission of the company
was ultimately the end goal
as you spoke just now it feels like you
know yourself so well you know the
missions that motivate you you know your
strengths and your weaknesses
what you know what you don't know and
i'm sure you remember
from the gsb we talk a lot about you
know
knowing ourselves and bringing our full
authentic selves to work and it seems
like you've
done that throughout your career and
it's got you to a lot of great places
so i'm curious to hear and this is kind
of a two-part question one
how did you go about discovering your
authentic self was it this aha moment
was it a journey was it deliberate or
subconscious
and then the second part of that is once
you did
discover yourself and do the work to
feel comfortable with who you are
both professionally and personally how
did you go about bringing that
into the workplace especially the parts
that might feel a little risky
to share i it's a journey
i don't know that i'm fully done
discovering
my authentic self i i'm i'm on a
constant
path to self-discovery after
i left taskrabbit a week after i did a
silent retreat
by myself for six days and i'd never
been alone by myself in that way before
and especially since
i've had two children in my home and
even those six days which happened
last year was a moment and a time for
self-discovery
i've i what i can say is that
my journey towards self-discovery has
really been
about the people around me who've
encouraged me to
to be my authentic self so sheryl
sandberg is a mentor of mine and a
really good friend
and she modeled that behavior so well at
google
and so when i started the black googler
network it was really about wait a
minute there's a whole part of me
that's missing from being inside this
company
and i want to feel like i belong in this
place
and so she encouraged me to think about
what are some of the ways that you can
do that and that's how
the black googler network was started
and even when it's harder it becomes
easier
as you get more senior people always say
that well once you become a vp or once
you become the ceo it's easy
to be your authentic self and i actually
don't think that's true
because in 2016 i stood up in front of
taskrabbit in july and talked about what
it's like to be black
and i i was so scared to have that con i
was the ceo
of the company i had just become the ceo
i could get up and say anything i wanted
but i was so scared about what people
would think
what would they think about well she's
going to talk about her experience
because we're seeing all these police
officers
kill black men but it was important to
me to get up in front of our company
meeting and not have a regular meeting
but to let them know who i am how i'm
feeling and the pain
that i was going through at the time and
so i think digging deep
and being willing to be vulnerable and
finding those moments where you're like
oh my god this is the vulnerable moment
those are the moments where it's
actually really good to be yourself
because what happened
after that was these this follow-up
conversation
from so many people in the company about
what it meant
to be from wherever they were from and
their personal stories
and then i ended up building closer
relationships
with my team in a way that i could never
have before
and so being vulnerable had really
helped me build deep connections
so when we went through the hard stuff
at taskrabbit which we in every
every day every company will like i had
a team with me and they knew me and they
understood me
and they were much more committed to the
vision and the strategy and the purpose
of what we were trying to do
it's a good reminder to know that you
know the journey never really stops i
mean you're
the ceo of taskrabbit you had 10 years
at google you're clearly
what's considered to be a silicon valley
insider but you still have those moments
where you have to navigate
you know feeling outside of yourself so
i i think that's a really good reminder
for everyone in the audience and
it sounds like you are so passionate
about
advocating for yourself and the people
in your corner and i can imagine that
that
contributed to a lot of your success at
taskrabbit because it's such a
human-centered company and i want to
talk about that because
i can imagine there are a lot of
challenges there with these companies
because sometimes the human-centered
decision
isn't always the best business decision
even if it's the right one
so i know when you got to taskrabbit you
had to make some tough calls
around that i'm specifically thinking
about the taskrabbit bidding structure
so you you got to task rabbit and you
decided to change the bidding structure
in which taskers had to bid to win jobs
because it often led to this
race to the bottom but you actually were
met with
quite a bit of backlash from that
decision and i would love for you to
share with the audience that
experience and what it meant to stick to
your guns in that moment
you know that was there's been some hard
decisions that i've had to make
in my career and in my life and that was
one of the hardest ones because when we
made
what was happening is that you had a 50
chance of getting your job done on
taskrabbit in our
in the first model when i joined the
company which was terrible from a
customer experience perspective
we couldn't really spend money on
marketing we were never going to be
profitable in that way so from a
business perspective it was bad
and so we decided to make this change
where you could hire the person directly
and you have more certainty around what
you got done
on the platform however to do that we
had to shrink the number of categories
which
meant that there were people who were
going to
not be able to find work on taskrabbit
anymore like
people who were depending on us to pay
their rent next month were going to wake
up the next day and realize
that that source of income was no longer
available to them
so it was hard but i knew that in order
to sustain the business
and to grow the business the way that we
wanted to we had to make this decision
and as a team we had some metrics so i
know you all learned about kpis we do
is these are the metrics like we know
where this is working
if the revenues look like this the
customer
net promoter score looks like this the
growth looks like this the category
changed you know we had all the data
and we had a plan so if in 60 days we're
not there
we got to go back we have to we have
like we got to revert back and so we had
a plan so we stuck to our plan
the backlash was where the mistake
happened which is
we we forgot we lost sight
of the community and we just talked
about community we had a community
of thousands of taskers who were
depending on us
and we didn't bring them along on the
journey we just sort of announced it
and said it's going to happen we kind of
talked to a council of taskers but we
didn't actually bring them
in to the process of the change and so
what i learned from that is that one the
community doesn't stop at
the people who work at your company it's
the people's lives that you're impacting
every day by the sheer nature of being
in business
and it's important as a leader and as a
company to talk about and communicate
what it is that you're doing that could
impact them and so we learned that
mistake we never made it again
we made other mistakes but we definitely
never made that one
again that's that's great and i i think
you know as you're talking through how
the level of which you're you're
beholden to the users of your platform
what comes to mind is obviously
proposition 22
where companies like uber and airbnb and
taskrabbit
are now at the forefront of these
discussions around
the level of responsibility they have to
their drivers their homeowners their
taskers i'd love to hear from you from
your
personal perspective what you think the
right balance is when it comes to
supporting
those users who are at the core of those
platforms
i have always felt from the day that i
joined taskrabbit
that the most important thing to do is
to listen to the customer
and in this case the customer is not
just the client who gets the work done
on the platform but it's the tasker
who's getting the work done
and the number one thing that they cared
about i don't care what any politician
or lawmaker or union leader
or whatever has to say is flexibility
the number one thing i have met taskers
who were
tears in their eyes literally telling me
thank you for giving me flexibility
because i'm a single mom
and i have to pick up my child from
school and this is the only way that i
can afford
to pay my bills what i think we missed
with proposition 22 and i'm glad i don't
work at taskrabbit anymore so i can talk
about it
you know what we missed was was the
focus on what was
really important and we got stuck on
what we're trying to get this company to
do this and we're trying to solve
this union issue and we're trying to
solve this
political issue and we lost sight of
really
fundamentally the problem we're trying
to solve which is to create
real economic opportunities i think
everybody
in their respective corners wants to
create real economic opportunities but
proposition 22
was a way to do that that just didn't
work for a lot of people
and so it failed and now i believe we
have to go back to the drawing board i
still
am an advocate for portable benefits i
do believe
that independent contractors whether
you're tasking on taskrabbit or driving
a car
or you're a doctor who are also
independent contractors
deserve to have affordable ways to take
care of their health
to save for retirement and take care of
themselves and for some reason
they can't work anymore and i think the
structures that we have today
aren't designed that way proposition 22
missed the mark in creating something
that was actually going to work
and we still have yet to build something
that is important
for this community if there's one thing
that 2020 has taught us
is that independent contractors and the
the nature of
that type of work is not going anywhere
in fact it has fueled the economy it has
stabilized people's homes it has given
people an option to work
when their traditional job furloughed
them so we we can't assume it's going to
go away and we're going to fit this
entire workforce of millions
into some other structure it is a time
to think about
a different structure and i think we
missed the mark but it doesn't mean that
we don't have a chance to go back
and come up with something better yeah
i think that really resonates with me um
as complicated and complex
as the gig economy and the companies
that operate within it
is i i personally have seen firsthand
the the opportunity that those companies
have created for people and communities
and
i think that's certainly here for the
long term and we
have to figure out everything around it
but i think overall adds so much value
to a lot of lives
and i think that's kind of a nice
transition into a very important topic i
want to touch on
as we start to come to a close here
which is the idea of legacy and impact
so you gave your resignation to
taskrabbit i believe around september
2019 with
the intent to leave soon thereafter but
that timeline changed with the pandemic
george floyd the resulting social
justice movements
i'm curious to hear how did you lead
taskrabbit
during i what would i would imagine is
like one of the most challenging times
for the company what did you do
internally and culturally to address or
acknowledge everything that was going on
specifically
or especially after having given your
resignation i'm sure that
was a weird moment to be in
i i was so committed to the company
that i was going to steer through a
successful transition so it was like it
was an easy meeting i served on the
board of
two public companies we've done
succession i said i know how to do this
i've heard it before i like i got my
scripts i went to the board i said it's
time
i'm going to transition here's my
timeline september 2019
like here you go and everyone's like oh
they're shocked but they're like okay
thank you we'll negotiate a timeline
worked it out
january came we're still on the timeline
february came wait a minute we're not on
the timeline
march right like whoa blown timeline
blown
me traveling in the summer with my kids
out the window
leaving in april like i planned gone so
those things were all going the timeline
was gone but
i cared a lot about leaving the company
in a great place we had built the
company we
launched four new countries in 18 months
we had built this amazing leadership
team
and i wanted nothing more than to see a
successful sort of handover
happen and so as the business started we
saw
seattle which was the first city that
had the
impact in the us with the pandemic and
our business dropped
and i was like oh boy this thing is
going to spread across the country and
spread across the world
and and our business is going to be
significantly impacted
the the most important thing that i
believe we did as a team was we focused
on our values
we focused on why are we here and what
are we trying to do and we were
fortunate enough
to be owned by ikea and a company that
thinks about things for the long term
so we put in a plan that said all right
if the numbers go this far south this is
what we have to do
if they go this far south this is what
we have to do and so we had that plan
fortunately our business recovered and
we didn't
lose as much revenue so we didn't have
to do any layoffs
but we had to pivot to focus on
categories
that were different we had to think
about whether or not to keep the
marketplace open
and this was something that was a really
important decision at the end of march
we had a board meeting and one of the
board members asked
well why aren't you shutting down the
marketplace because people go into
people's homes you could be spreading
the virus
to others and people could die and my
response i had to think a lot about what
to say
i said well we've got thousands of
taskers who've reached out to us and
said please don't shut down the
marketplace this is the only source of
income that i have and if i can't pay my
rent
i can't take care of my family and i
can't buy food so you've got a board
member who's like
protecting the risk of the company and
then you've got taskers who's like
please i need money and our our number
one value as a company is caring deeply
and it really was about caring for the
whole community
the whole not just the employees not
just the people who work there but the
entire community the people who use the
service and benefit from the service and
provided as well
so we made a decision i said look we're
not going to shut down but we are going
to do
is we're going to focus on these
categories we're going to provide all of
our taskers with the ppe
for free we're going to do this and
we're going to do this because
there's a whole bunch of people who need
to work so being grounded in those
values
helped us weather this storm of this
pandemic and
by the time i left i was fortunate that
we recovered back to our pre-covet
growth levels and revenue levels and so
i was able to transition out and not
leave the new ceo with a lot to
handle other than the remainder of this
pandemic which i'm sure she will do a
great job with
i'm sure i mean it's absolutely
remarkable that you
steered a company like taskrabbit that
is so dependent on human interaction and
contact through
that period and came out the other side
uh remarkably well and i'm curious as
you were leaving
how are you thinking about your own
legacy personally
and the impact you wanted to have um
once departing from taskrabbit were you
concerned at all that leaving a ceo
title might
impact or stall or impede that in any
way
not at all i
believe the identity of a ceo is
something that
gets put on you it's sort of like
oh you're the ceo and people look at you
differently they treat you differently
they don't want to
you they don't want anyone who's on this
ceo you don't get all the inside
information anymore on the company
everyone's like
prepared when they come to the meeting
so there is this identity that is put
on you but i never let it become me i
never let it become who i was
people would ask me you know don't you
want your kids to come to this because
you're you're talking
you're going to interview michelle obama
and some other stuff
and they just kind of didn't really care
like i have a six-year-old nine-year-old
like no
mommy i want her to read me a story and
help me find my toy because i can't find
it right now they were very good
at grounding me and what was important
so when i think about
legacy it's not about the ceo i can have
an impact
independent of being a ceo and so as you
know i launched the opportunity fund
with softbanks 100 million dollar fund
focused on investing in black
latinx and native american founders and
that was after i left
decided to leave my job there's so many
different ways that each of us as
individuals
can impact the communities around us so
i wasn't worried about not having that
title
and my kids helped me make sure that
that wasn't as important as
you know finding the toy which i still
did
yesterday even so
renaissance woman i think that's i think
that's totally
fantastic and you know you're in this
period of pause and
you're thinking through your priorities
as you said spending time with your
children
going on a silent retreat how else are
you using this time to kind of
figure out what your next mountain looks
like and are you eager to do that or
kind of just letting yourself
explore i am eager and i am exploring
okay i'm enjoying the process i will say
there's a lot of things
driving by some slow some fast
and i'm enjoying the process i really
love
building companies and i'm enjoying the
process
of the opportunity fund i mean we
started
and created a fund inside of a very
large company
but we're doing it in a different way so
i'm enjoying the process of being on
that investment committee
helping to show great founders who have
great ideas
that there are venture firms out there
that will return your phone call
treat you with respect if we're not
going to invest we will tell you why
for real and if we are going to invest
we're going to support you 100
all the way through so that's a new
learning for me
so i'm just enjoying the process of
exploring and learning
and having a lot of fun amazing i'm so
excited to
follow the opportunity fund i think it's
once in a lifetime and such an
incredible
thing you're doing so i'm going to turn
it over now to my classmates we're going
to ask you a few
questions and then we'll come back here
to wrath
um so first we have kate
hi stacy thank you so much for being
here i'm kate mba1
and my question is forward-looking so
how do you envision
labor market and especially freelance
labor market
in 10 years from now wow
i i think it's fundamentally different
from where it is
today we are doing this
zoom from home i just got off the call
with somebody who is decided to go 100
virtual how we work and the way that we
work
has fundamentally changed and all the
things that we that we're going to take
five years to do
happened basically in seven months
and i look at that from a bunch of
different perspectives but one is
as a board member of hp they were
selling very large printers
to go to your be in your office building
that's basically what they did
and now they're like wait a minute the
office buildings aren't there they're
not going to be as many people we've got
to refactor
our entire product strategy and our
sales strategy
to accommodate smaller environments and
working from home
so i believe that the way that people
will work
has changed forever so in 10 years it's
hard for me to predict
how much more it'll be different what i
do know is that
the the personalization that we've
achieved
by creating work environments that are
much more integrated i just told you my
kids will
come my dog already went by once right
it's got to get more personal
and we can't separate the work from the
home we can't separate
you know my identity as a mom and a wife
from my identity as
you know a vp or an executive or a ceo i
am
all those things and how we work and how
we create
the best work environments for people to
thrive in has to encompass
all those things i really see
independent contractors like i said
earlier they're not going
that that whole infrastructure is not
going anywhere
so i'm hoping that as we think about
developing new laws
at the federal and the state level those
laws will embrace
an economy that is ultimately here to
stay
you stacy and next we have irving
hi stacy thanks so much for speaking to
us today
my name is irving i'm an admitted
student to the gsb
my question for you is as you think back
to your time at stanford
what were some of the most valuable
lessons you took from the gsb that have
influenced your personal leadership
style
wow i i have so many so i'll do the like
touchy-feely one because you're all
wondering i'm sure
um i i i took i came
to stanford from a very
financial background i went to wharton
undergrad
i worked in public accounting and then i
worked in investment banking
so i really wanted to round out a lot of
my
analytical and finance skills and so i
took
marketing and organizational behavior
and all those classes
help me see that leadership is way more
than the spreadsheets
even though i was like a master at excel
like
i was really good i'm not good anymore
but i was really really good
some of the things that really helped me
is one just taking touchy-feely
like that class helped me see how other
people see me
and really understand the difference
between how you
show up and how other people see you i
can't think of
there's so many times as a manager where
people say well i tried to do this i
told them this
and i said well it doesn't really matter
what you said what matters is what they
heard and how they interpreted what you
said and i
learned that fundamental principle as
part of taking
taking touchy feeling so that's one of
the biggest things
thank you thanks cece i know i'm
really eager to take touchy feely i'm on
the waitlist so we'll see if i get in
next ring
so we have one last question for you
that we're asking all of our leaders
this year which is what principles do
you rely on when facing your toughest
moments as a leader
for me the absolute number one is
integrity
uh one of my favorite quotes which is
not
gender appropriate anymore but i'm going
to say it the way that he said it
is by dr martin luther king which is the
ultimate
measure of a man is not how he stands in
times of comfort and convenience but how
he stands in times
of challenge and controversy so we can
substitute the he
with she or they however but i want you
all to hear
how it was originally written and i
think about that
because that really calls into question
character
and when everything's fine we're all
fine but when everything's not fine
do you come with the sense of integrity
do you bring
the best person that you are to the
table
and that's really what guides me and
what i hope guides the people who decide
to work with me and for me
that's really inspiring i love that
quote i've never heard that before
um and i think we're all you know
walking away from this conversation
feeling motivated to bring our best
selves and our integrity
to work after seeing all that you've
accomplished and after seeing how you've
modeled such a wonderful career for so
many people
so thank you so much for being here
today it's been wonderful speaking with
you
thank you this was fun jessica thank you
so much
thanks stacy